[Music]
thank you all for coming out tonight you
know it is a it is a special night
tonight for science do you who knows
what I'm referring to the anniversary do
you know what I'm talking about somebody
what is it well yes but light Falls is
celebrating a particular event in the
history of science which was
confirmation of Einstein's general
theory of relativity 100 years ago today
Eclipse observations were used to
confirm the prediction that Einstein
made in summon made reference indeed we
do have a program on tonight on PBS so
after this program if you want more you
can run home turn on channel 13 from 10
to 11:30 you have a program that was
filmed on this very stage in February
but tonight our focus is upon a related
idea that has a deep connection to
theories of gravity our understanding of
the force of gravity because we're going
to be discussing the possibility that
many scientists have bought into over
the course of many decades that there's
much more to the universe out there that
meets the eye and the reason that we've
come to this conclusion is by virtue of
studying the gravitational poles that
happen out there in the cosmos and
coming to the conclusion that the stuff
that we see is unable to give rise to
the gravitational pull that we observe
and one way of thinking about this just
to kind of get into the subject is to
imagine that you know you're flying into
New York City at night many of us
perhaps all of us have done this and as
you fly in at night of course all that
you really can see are the lights in the
buildings now we all know when we see an
image like this that there is more
structure to the image to the reality
than the lights themselves how do we
know that well because we all have an
intuitive understanding of gravity and
if there were no buildings if there were
no structure out there
these lights they'd fall down to the
ground and because they don't fall we
know that there is something out there
that's holding them
and of course by the light of day we can
begin to see what that structure
actually is and of course we all know
what the structure is it is the
architecture the physical makeup of the
buildings themselves but without being
able to see that structure itself if we
only have access to the light which is
all that we have access to when we look
out to the universe we have to infer the
existence of the dark stuff that's not
visible at the moment and that's how we
come to this conclusion that when we're
talking about not a cityscape but the
universe that there might be more out
there than meets the eye so this is an
idea actually it has a long history and
I won't take you through the full
history it's a fascinating story but
I'll just give you some highlights of it
toward the end of the 1800s as we began
to have ever greater ability to observe
the night sky scientists began to try to
really understand the motion of stars
out there and one scientists in
particular Lord Kelvin he had this idea
to model the stars out there in the
galaxy as if they were perhaps molecules
in a box of gas you know those scales
are completely different but the idea
was to apply the understanding of how
particles move inside of a box of gas
apply the same ideas now to stars moving
within a galaxy and when he did that
analysis he came to the conclusion that
there might be stuff out there that we
can't see in fact in his own words he
described it like this it is
nevertheless probable that there may be
as many as a billion stars but many of
them may be extinct and dark and
nine-tenths of them though not all dark
may not be bright enough to be seen by
us at their actual distances many of our
stars perhaps a great majority of them
may be dark bodies so the possibility
that perhaps the majority of stuff
that's out there might be dark this is
an idea now the
going way way back late 1800s and then
another great mathematician scientists
on Ray Poincare a he was inspired by
kelvins analysis to do his own version
of that analysis and he came to a
different conclusion but he did
introduce an important phrase that's yes
obscure he did it in French of course
but of course that is dark matter so
this idea of dark matter goes all the
way back to the late 1800s Early 1900s
and as people began to think about this
idea over the ensuing decades it's this
fella right here do you know who this is
anybody know this is Ricky yeah Fritz
Zwicky who was a Swiss American
astronomer kind of a wonderful character
but he began to study the motion of
galaxies in the Coma Cluster this is a
few hundred light years away and again
he found that the motion of the galaxies
was such that it couldn't be solely due
to the ingredients that he could see by
virtue of their light he concluded that
there had to be additional dark stuff
that was out there that would be
responsible for the gravity that was
pushing and pulling these galaxies
around but it's really the work of this
person right here Vera Rubin who really
cinched the case in the minds of many
physicists many astronomers for the
existence of dark stuff that's out there
because what she did was she studied the
motion of stars in swirling galaxies and
found that the galaxies are swirling too
quickly the stars should be sort of
ejected out right now one way of
thinking about this we can do a little
quick demonstration of this you know if
you have for instance a very simple
pedestrian situation where you have a a
wheel right and you have water on the
wheel and we all know we don't have to
do this but it's sort of fun to see it
if you take this wheel and it's spinning
slowly enough very little water will fly
off but of course you give it a real
spin and the water droplets fly right
off thank you very much
and the idea the idea was that the
galaxies were spinning as fast as I was
spinning the wheel said that the Stars
should be flying off as the water did
but Vera Rubin found that the stars are
not flying off and therefore there had
to be something else that was pulling
them in something else that's dark
because we don't see it giving rise to
the gravitational pull that was holding
the galaxies together and of course it
wasn't just pictures
there was mathematical analysis behind
this when you do the mathematics which
we won't go into any detail on but the
expectation was that the farther out you
go from the center of the galaxy the
slower the Stars should be moving but in
fact her observations and analysis
showed that that wasn't seeming the case
the speed of the stars out on the edge
of the galaxy was too fast relative to
what we thought it should be they should
be flying off but they weren't and
therefore this notion that there should
be some dark stuff that would be out
there and when you put the numbers into
it you find something rather remarkable
if you calculate the amount of dark
matter that must be out there to hold
these galaxies together you find that
it's four five times as much as the
amount of matter the protons neutrons
electrons that makes us up so you're
talking the majority of the matter in
the universe might be dark stuff and
indeed we'll even talk about a different
kind but perhaps related dark entity
called dark energy later in the program
as well bottom line is the stuff that
makes up you me and everybody else maybe
as tiny sliver of the mass energy budget
of the entire universe and that's a
remarkable pie chart they're showing us
we know a lot about reality but it might
be that a lot of our focus has been on
the tiny piece of the full story
now before bringing out the participants
who will discuss this further with us I
want to mention one point that's
actually related to the anniversary the
hundredth anniversary of the general
theory of relativity which is this
when Einstein
was doing his calculations on relativity
in November of 1915 he focuses attention
on a particular puzzle particular
problem that had to do with the motion
of the planet Mercury it had been known
for a long time that Mercury's orbit
wasn't doing what the gravitational
equations said that it should instead
the orbit was kind of shifting a little
bit each year and to explain this
shifting orbit some astronomers
introduced the possibility that maybe
there is a dark planet out there called
Vulcan a hidden planet undetected planet
that was tugging on Mercury and that's
what was causing the orbit to shift this
was the going idea until Einstein came
along and with a deeper understanding of
the force of gravity and his general
theory of relativity was able to fully
explain the data without any dark stuff
which is just to say that you have to
have an open mind as we'll see in the
discussion going forward maybe there's
dark stuff out there but maybe our
understanding of gravity needs to be
deepened as this historical example
shows us and perhaps a deeper
understanding of the force of gravity
might explain the anomalous observation
so this is a point that we will come
back to but the bottom-line question
that we will be discussing is it the
case that much like this cityscape we
see the light stuff the Stars the lights
in the buildings is there additional
dark stuff out there and if there is
what is it made of those are the
questions for tonight and we are
fortunate to have some of the world's
experts to discuss these questions with
us to illuminate these deep puzzles so
let's now bring them out our first
participant is the director of the Kavli
Institute for particle astrophysics and
cosmology he's playing a leading role in
modeling and mapping out tens of
billions of galaxies to understand the
evolution of the universe and the nature
of dark matter and dark energy please
welcome Risa Wexler
[Music]
our next participant is a professor of
physics and astronomy at Johns Hopkins
University and a science writer and
author his work on the cosmic microwave
background galaxy formation exploration
of nature dark matter
please welcome Joe silk
all right also joining us tonight is an
associate professor of physics at
Princeton University whose research
focuses on the nature of dark matter she
has tested theories of dark matter using
data from a wide range of experiments
please welcome Maria Angela Santi all
right our final guest tonight is a
professor of theoretical physics at the
University of Amsterdam his research
deals with string theory quantum gravity
black holes and cosmology he's a
recipient of the Spinoza prize the
highest award available to Dutch
scientists please welcome Eric Berlin
day
[Music]
all right thank you all for being here
for this discussion of dark stuff out
there in the universe and I just want to
begin by amplifying the point that I was
making at the very end so when we're
thinking about this puzzle that there's
motion in the universe that seems that
we can't explain it using the stuff that
we can see using light there seems to be
two general ways of addressing this
problem it could be that there's more
stuff out there than meets the eye there
could be dark stuff you can actually
bring this up on the screen if you with
these two possibilities but it could
also be that our understanding of the
forces and particularly force of gravity
needs sort of a deeper explanation a
more full understanding much as
Einstein's general theory of relativity
did that for the motion of the planet
Mercury so part of our discussion
tonight will be these two possibilities
and I'll just sort of lay out the the
teams if you will so these three folks
over here I think it's fair to say
you're more on the dark stuff side of
the explanatory possibilities and over
there on the far left side or far right
side from your perspective is Erik for
Linda
one of the most thoughtful creative
insightful physicists that I have ever
met in my entire life so not to bias the
conversation but he has a very
interesting but I think it's fair to say
speculative idea which is more on the
right side of the explanation there so
just just quickly where where do you see
your ideas fitting in this did you feel
that there developed to the point where
there a competitor to the dark stuff
that will be some of the focus or it's
still very much a work in progress so
busy understanding gravity in a more
fundamental way I mean many colleagues I
do this with who are trying to combine
general relativity with quantum
mechanics with using string theory and
this has developed into a new framework
in which we can explain actually where
gravity comes from from a more
microscopic picture and I indeed believe
that we can then explain these phenomena
without the need for dark matter
but this is a theory that well has sort
of started to become developed but we
need to do more work to be ventually get
the complete thing out there so it's not
like I can explain everything yet but
there's a first hint of a new theory and
then indeed you don't need the dark
matter particles to explain this extra
gravity that we have been observing and
just to give a snapshot so that folks
who aren't following the details of this
in the research literature is this a
minority opinion equal of page how would
you sort of frame the number of people
who are thinking this way versus the
dark stuff certainly a minority and and
of course I'd like to encourage more
people to think about it this way and
it's I think that once we start trying
to understand gravity better and have
developed that theory this will come out
automatically but this will take some
time and so it's fair to say that I I'm
not certainly in the majority but
there's a well hope hopefully a growing
number of people taking my point of view
and so as we focus our attention for the
first part on the dark stuff you're
gonna be able to withstand this
obviously good no I I mean I can
understand even the logic for it and
yeah so it's certainly something that's
well motivated so I can even great
executive all right just so by chapter
three of this discussion we're gonna
come to a focus but let's for the first
two parts focus on the the left-hand
side and when we're talking about dark
stuff the natural thought that might
come to mind it's the kind of stuff that
we know about maybe it's planets maybe
it's stars that have burned out maybe
it's black holes that are out there in
the universe that's sort of one
collection of possibilities the other
collection is fundamental ingredients
that make up those entities particles
perhaps the ones we know about
or perhaps hypothetical particles so
let's just start on the on the left-hand
column here Joe could it be that the
dark stuff is just things that we know
about that are hard to see because they
don't give off light we know about
ordinary stars
and we infer from things we're going to
talk about there's lots of dark matter
so could there not be dark stars now we
have extremely tight constraints on how
much ordinary matter there could be in
the universe even in dark form because
long ago in the first minutes of the Big
Bang this stuff was just ordinary matter
although it's now a Dark Star and we'd
participate in thermonuclear reactions
that made all the helium in the universe
a wonderful prediction of The Big Bang
Theory the lightest element the second
lightest of mother hydrogen and very
very abundant and that great success
tells us that the amount of this dot
baryonic
doc stellar stuff it's it's a small
fraction it can't be the dark matter
which then leads us to consider more
exotic things and so one intriguing
possibility is the possibility of black
holes that were formed very early in the
universe and so these would be ideal
dark candidates because we simply can't
see them and the interesting thing is
you can decide how many might be left
over because they do affect light
transmission from stars in nearby
galaxies they deflect the light slightly
as as they might pass by in front of the
background star and so this is like just
landing which again just for the
historical fact is again the very
experiment that was done a hundred years
that's right it's a version of
Einstein's original prediction and and
it's a way of indirectly inferring how
many dark stars there can be and so
we're now at the point where we can set
limits on the possibilities of these
dark stars over a huge range in masses
and it turns out that you can people
have studied for example the the nearest
galaxies they have looked at stars that
would be slightly affected by a passing
black hole and they can say that at most
10% of the dark matter could be
in massive stars or small stars or but
what is left over very exciting
possibility are really really tiny black
holes essentially the masses of
asteroids but black holes and so
incredibly tiny but there are there
could be a lot of them and enough of
them to essentially evade all possible
constraints from this twinkling effect
on stars lensing of stars and the
exciting thing about the newest day that
we have which consists of staring at
largest nearby galaxy the Andromeda
galaxy for a long time and looking again
for slight variations in star patterns
and we're beginning you know there are
even reports that they've found the
first event that might be what they call
a primordial black hole from the
beginning roughly asteroid mass we have
to take a lot more data there could be
more but the beauty of this hypothesis
is that we're not inventing any new
physics right not inventing new
particles we're taking known physics we
know that black holes can form they do
form massive ones from dead stars and
now we actually have a photograph of a
black hole so I think it's a it's a
wonderful hypothesis that again has
enormous potential we're just beginning
to explore but if you wanted my vote on
what the dark matter could be I will put
this high on the list of possible
candidates the alternative being
elementary particles that will be
discussed in a moment left over also
from the Big Bang gotcha so let's hold
that as a possibility one of the
candidates for the dark stuff might be
these black holes that were formed the
very early universe but now let's turn
to the other possibility that you
mentioned which is elementary particles
the stuff that makes up familiar matter
from stars to people to rocks and so
forth now there are a number of
possibilities so let's start real simple
could the dark matter just be an
electron could it be a lot of electrons
out there could it be neutrons
could it be protons could
that kind of stuff well we're pretty
sure that all this extra matter has got
to be charged neutral because if it were
electrons would be have electric force
on one side protons on another side will
be a disaster we could rule that out
completely
yeah something neutral works and
something stable works neutrons decay
they're unstable so it couldn't be
neutrons although they're neutrals at
10-15 minutes they're there that's right
and we also need a particle that
interacts very weakly with other
particles
unlike electrons and protons which make
up the Stars the earth etc this dark
stuff is outside the boundaries of where
we see the stars so it's a particle that
interacts weakly and basically we have
to invent a new class of particles to be
candidates for the dark matter and so we
we do have a wonderful theory which
predicts such particles
it's called supersymmetry it postulates
that very early on there were equal
numbers of all types of particles
partners of each other and the heavier
partner which had a slightly different
spin would be unstable but the lightest
of those will be left behind and could
be the dark matter that's a prediction
of this very elegant theory which hasn't
been actually verified yet but it argues
for perfect symmetry and the very early
stages of the universe so it's
compelling for that reason so you
mentioned supersymmetry yes and so this
is a theory that particle physics folks
come up with not to solve the dark
matter problem they the introduce it for
differently so part of the the
attractive feature of black holes was
that you didn't have to invent something
new is already within the equations so
Eric just very briefly why do physicists
particle physicists in particular
introduce this idea of supersymmetry and
just to lead you in the direction I have
you know we we have another program in
the first about the Higgs particle so
what's the relevant to this for that may
indeed I mean it's a beautiful idea for
support theoretically that we can relate
the particles in the standard model to
so there
but something nice happens there namely
there's a big puzzle in the standard
model this Higgs particle and has been
found
we like to understand understand explain
also why the mass that it has stays that
value and it turns out that if you add
these other mirror particles the
supermassive metric partners that we can
explain this in a very natural way and
so the whole standard model works
actually more beautifully if we add the
supersymmetry
I mean string theory actually also
predicts the supersymmetry so also from
string theory would have been very happy
to find it and fortunately it has not
been found yet but the idea is still
alive and it's one of those more
beautiful theoretical ideas that we hope
is realized in nature so mariangela so
up on up on the screen here we have the
left hand side is the stuff that we've
long known about the quarks that make up
the protons and neutrons and so forth
the right hand side are the particles
that Joanne Derek referring to these
these additional particles just point
out the ones that we've we've actually
seen just that we know which ones are
actually real everything on the left
we've seen with the Higgs being the most
recent one in 2012 and actually this is
coming back to the question you asked
before which is of everything that we've
seen can anything actually be the dark
matter and it would be good to point out
that the neutrinos which are the ones
that look like a little squiggle v's yep
are probably the only thing in the
standard model that has the
characteristics that we'd want to be
dark matter in the sense that they're
neutral and very weakly interacting so
they're not emitting any kind of light
otherwise we would have seen them yep
and so the trouble with the neutrinos is
that you can do a calculation and ask
how much of the current amount of dark
stuff that's here now can be comprised
she knows it's a very tiny fraction
small to small so that's how we know
that the standard model on its own can't
account for all of the dark matter so if
we then hypothesize these Susy particles
here on the right there are some
candidates in this in this assortment
that have the same kind of
characteristics neutral give you the
correct stability the stable so they
give you the correct abundance today and
interact very weakly but everything on
the right we have intact
observed yet yep and you know when I
first started in graduate school there
was a going lore which is if you wanted
to write your first paper you just make
up a dark matter a candidate you know
motivated from these ideas you do sort
of a calculations I don't know if you if
you happen to have the first paper that
I wrote out there I thought it would be
kind of fun to to show it to you simply
because human eyes will never look at
this paper again because it's just not
important it's just sort of there it is
so it's seen the light of day now we can
put it back into the journal and we'll
never see it again
but but this is the idea so there's the
possibility of exotic particles that
what presumably they be produced in the
in shortly after the Big Bang and then
and then how do you figure out how many
of these particles would remain so
imagine the Big Bang happens there's all
this energy what's the what's the step
is it is is there a well-defined
procedure to figuring out how much of
those dark particles will still be
hanging around today yes indeed there is
so and it's very predictive so what we
need to know is how the dark matter
particles interact with the standard
model so that's where we have to make
some kind of Theory assumption but if we
do that then we can start modeling how
these dark matter particles are
interacting with all regular matter in
the very early universe so you might
have to dark matter particles come in
interact give you some regular matter
and vice versa and the whole system can
be in equilibrium so the forward
reaction happening with equal rate as
the backward reaction but as a function
of time what ends up happening is the
universe is expanding and so if you have
two dark matter particles at some point
with the universe's expansion they'll no
longer be able to find each other
anymore and so finding is important
because that's how they yes findings
reporting is and that's how they can
interact to give you the standard and
when they interact they disappear by
producing more exactly yeah so once they
can no longer find each other then
they're just this interaction stops and
and then however many dark matter
particles are around at that point in
time stays essentially constant until
today and that's the the amount that we
measure so you can actually calculate
what this interaction rate is accounting
for the expansion of the universe and
a specific prediction for the manager so
we have a rough version of that
calculation right here and of course you
don't have to understand the mathematics
behind this but the point is there is a
well-defined rigorous mathematical
procedure it allows us to figure out how
much of this dark stuff would be hanging
around and the wonderful beautiful
perhaps unexpected fact is that when you
do this calculation for supersymmetric
particles the typical amount that will
remain for the stable ones is pretty
close to the amount of dark matter that
observations suggest should be out there
now when I learned that as a student I
was bowled over by this I was like of
course as ever even many were - it has
to be the dark matter how else could it
be the case that the amount that is left
over is just what we need and then when
you guys learn that did you have a
similar reaction or you just sort of see
this as a coincidence or or something
else to me there only is new but I mean
you're tweaking two numbers one that's
in the numerator and the other one's in
the denominator and you pick two values
where it works but what happens if you
change those ratios a little bit then
you all of a sudden open up a much wider
region of the parameter true but just to
push back a little bit the natural
values of those parameters like the mass
of the particle being you know one to a
hundred times the mass of a proton feels
very natural the rate at which they
annihilate that's not really put in by
hand it's using the interaction rate of
the weak interact you know so there's
very natural choices that still didn't
that was compelling but it also did the
the numerology aspect of it always did
make me feel a little uncomfortable is
this point that mariangela made that if
it's not that the parameter space opens
up a lot and so that's an interesting
situation we're in I mean I think it's
interesting that the interesting paper
that the original papers where where it
was seem like wow that's amazing
yep those models have actually already
been ruled out and so now we have a much
broader parameter space that we have to
look at but right but in the old days
when there
amazing thing and that sort of drove the
focus on a particular category of dark
matter candidates called wimps yes I
didn't want to say so thank you so so so
so wimp stands for what weakly
interacting massive particle and the
supersymmetric partners provide a class
of candidates that fit that particular
description and could be the Dark Matter
yeah I mean several over the print of
the of the particles that mariangela was
already talking about be wimps so if
this is a viable possibility the key
thing of course is to go out and find
these particles and that is something
that we've been trying to do for a while
so maryland's it can take us through the
the approaches that people have put
forward to try to actually capture one
of these particles or create one of them
sure yeah so with with wimps in
particular there's a three-pronged
approach so the first being let's try to
produce it in the lab and in that case
you look at some really powerful
Collider like the Large Hadron Collider
where you take two protons and you
collide them together really high-energy
and you hope that in that high energy
collision you might actually be able to
produce some new heavy exotic state that
might be the Dark Matter particle so
using the energy of the incoming
particles and equals MC squared you want
to transmute that energy into this
exotic folk that's right and in some
sense if we can create this in the lab
that's the best scenario because then
it's in a controlled environment we
could go in and we can really study the
you know and get at the particle physics
properties of that particle alright
how's that going we haven't seen it yet
[Laughter]
but not for want of trying really really
hard right okay and we're still still
trying right it's not as though the game
is over but so far I mean the LHC has
been running for the last few years and
will be continuing to run so far we
haven't seen anything but you know
people are you know there's gonna be
more data and people are coming up with
new and creative ways of analyzing it so
we never know when that surprises so
that's one approach trying to actually
create it in the laboratory other
approach the other approach is to to
look it for it in the sky look I'm sorry
to look forward in the sky yes so if you
have
to dark matter particles that interact
they could sometimes very rarely but
sometimes produce a little flash of
light right and so you can look for this
annihilation process by searching in
parts of galaxies where you expect there
there might be a lot of dark matter and
see whether or not there's an excess of
light over what you would have otherwise
have expected to see and how's that
going
also the lots of data we haven't seen it
yet again not for want of trying really
really hard and Jody would that be your
assessment the beautiful part of this
argument is the very same effects that
stop this particles being created in the
early universe still give you a value of
their interactions if ever they could
find one another they would produce
again a flash of gamma-rays actually
yeah a cascade of quarks and whatever
and so the trick is you look in the vast
depths of galactic space the volumes are
so large that you can look for the
cumulation of these rare events and look
for gamma rays you can see here the
gamma-ray sky as measured by - what
gamma rays are just silly okay they're
photons which are thousands of times
more energetic and penetrating the next
age okay there are hundreds of MeV
x-rays rkv so really really hard photons
produced in nuclear explosions I mean if
ever you're unfortunate enough to be
near a nuclear explosion then you would
be rated by gamma rays that would be one
of the the more catastrophic things that
could happen to you but fortunately the
gamma rays don't get through the Earth's
atmosphere that we look for them from
satellites in space so and there they
can penetrate can propagate freely and
so in the center of our Milky Way galaxy
which is where the dark matter mostly
accumulates you would expect there to be
a slight excess of gamma rays if the
dark matter is indeed the WIMP type of
dark matter and so many years ago even
before the this firm this satellite was
launched to look at the gamma rays there
were hints there was an excess of
something very far
going on there based on radio
observations then when the gamma-ray
satellites are taking data and they
model all the various contributions of
gamma rays for example you get gamma
rays when high-energy cosmic rays hit
ordinary clouds of gas they've been as
gamma rays but you know exactly where
the clouds of gas are you know what the
cosmic rays are so you can correct fall
of this and when they did this they
found it in the central degrees of our
Milky Way there's this tiny excess of
gamma rays not explainable by anything
known at that time and so straight away
the particle theorists the dark matter
addicts said this could well be the
signature been looking for of
annihilation dark matter and Eiling with
itself and giving you gamma rays and
they said well if we take exactly the
same interaction strength that's
predicted from the fundamental theory
and we take the standard model which
you'll hear about in a little bit for
the Dark Matter distribution in galaxies
lo and behold to get the right flux and
that looked very attractive it wasn't
quite proof because there's always a
bunch of sceptics around and the
skeptics said well look we know there
are certain types of stars they're
rapidly spinning pulsars which the Fermi
satellite also saw and they said weather
could be a lot of those in the center
but so faint that they're really hard to
see but in humouredly they could give
you the diffuse gamma rays and so the
jury is sort of out on one side or the
other it could be the Dark Matter very
elusive it could be these missing bozos
so there's a new test we can do which
we're trying desperately to do now there
are tiny galaxies going around the Milky
Way dwarf galaxies which are full of
dark matter very few stars and they
almost certainly don't have these
distracting millisecond also gamma ray
sources right and so we're looking at
those I'm staring at them with this
gamma ray telescope to look for evidence
of gamma rays there are you know we've
looked at twenty of them one sees the
gamma rays from one or two at marginal
levels so it's impossible to stay
statistically
whether we found them or not all we can
say is we need bigger and better
telescopes that satellite was built down
the hall for me and when the people were
working on it I think we really hoped
that when it launched we would sort of
immediately see those brilliant signals
from those dwarf galaxies yep and that
didn't happen so you know there were
models that could have been whip
versions of the wimp which could have
had booming signals from dwarf galaxies
and we're definitely not seeing that
gotcha so we've ruled out a bunch of
things the same excess that we see from
the center of the galaxy if that sort of
Dark Matter when the dwarfs we would be
marginally seeing it now we need bigger
telescopes that's the or what the
astronomers always say so let's turn to
telescopes and and thinking about
cosmology so Risa this is an area that
that you've spent a lot of time working
on Dark Matter as a key ingredient in
how the universe has evolved and how
structure has formed so let's now turn
to looking into the deep sky for the
signatures of dark matter so so tell us
some of the approaches that have been
used to figure out the role of dark
matter in the formation of the things
that we know about the the galaxies and
other structure in the universe we
talked already about how dark matter you
know if there is dark matter if it's a
particle it's you know four or five
times the amount of normal matter yep so
we can take that model and we can say
well what does that predict for what
happens over the last 13 billion years
in the universe yeah so that model first
it predicts something about what
fluctuations there should be very early
on in the universe which we can measure
from the Cosmic Microwave Background
we say fluctuations I mean places where
the universe is there's a little bit of
extra stuff and a little bit less stuff
so so we my understanding of gravity is
not as complicated as Eric's so most of
what I do is just think about the same
kind of gravity that you and I interact
with the earth or you know the Earth
rotates around the Sun so that kind of
gravity we can put that into our
computers and we can take the fact that
there were little places in the universe
which were a little bit more dense or a
little bit less than
and we can turn out on gravity and so we
can actually figure out what kind of
structure forms in the universe in that
context and the idea is where it's a
little bit denser it pulls in more so
yeah right and where there's a little
bit less stuff you know you get empty
regions when you do that you can
actually make predictions also then of
where the galaxies should form and in
our current theory of galaxy formation
yep one side of the screen yes was a
prediction from those simulations of
dark matter and how the structure forms
in a model where you know 85% of the
mass is dark matter the other side is is
actual observations where we're actually
going out and mapping the galaxies
distribution and this is just a computer
you put in there you put it in there you
see what happens essentially whenever
you get enough dark matter in one place
that's where you expect a galaxy to form
basically you get enough you get enough
dark matter then the gas can start to
cool and form stars and this on the
right hand side those observations are
from a telescope called the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey which actually mapped
the positions in 3d of about you know
about two million galaxies actually
later this year we're going to start
kind of the next generation of that
called the dark energy spectroscopic
instrument we're going to get about 10
times as many galaxies and so we'll have
a much better map of what that looks
like but the point is if looking at this
beautiful video the left hand side the
right hand side they look they basically
look the same right
yeah and so this is actually what this
is actually showing is that the other
thing that dark matter does so it forms
that structure and that structure just
like we talked about gravitational
lensing with with the perihelion a
mercury it just how we talked about
gravitational lensing with those micro
lensing events it impacts the shape of
galaxies a tiny bit so if a galaxy were
round it gets distorted it looks tiny
bit it looks distorted because it's
light got distorted over the several
billion years that it took to get to us
because because there was stuff in the
way and that stuff we assume is the dark
matter and it has an impact that's right
so so that stuff if it is dark matter
actually changes the shapes of galaxies
and so the thing you're seeing here is
is actually a map of where all of the
mass in the universe is inferred from
the positions of these galaxies so that
was a map made by the dark energy survey
and actually this map here you're seeing
this is the first time it's been shown
in public this is one eighth of the sky
it just tells what the color code so the
color code basically tells you about
where the mass is in the universe so and
and and this is actually looking at the
mass primarily about six billion years
ago okay so these are the these are
galaxies that span all the way from sort
of 1 billion light-years away to about 7
billion light years away and so and
there's I think about a hundred million
galaxies that went into making this map
over one-eighth of the sky and we're
actually seeing where in the universe is
there more stuff or less stuff and by
measuring how this evolves over time we
actually also learn something about the
expansion history of the universe which
tells us about dark energy so overall
through these simulations and through
the relationship to observations you are
honing an ever more precise
understanding of how much dark matter
there is and its distribution throughout
the universe so this I gather is just
adding more and more weight to your
argument that the dark stuff is it's
real and it's actually out there so so
from the work that you've done what
would you say is the most I mean do you
ever ask yourself whether the dark stuff
is real or is that just a foregone
conclusion and the approach that you you
take in your work on a day to day basis
I sort of assume it's there because it's
a model that works extremely well so we
can you know we can use that model and
we can make a huge number of predictions
so the things that I talked about
already it allows us to say how much
there is and where it is but it doesn't
tell you what it is so our best guess is
that it's a particle but there are other
possibilities and you know there could
be other possibilities that give you the
same distribution of galaxies
the same distribution of mass and I
think one of the interesting things is
that there are clues so the things we
talked about so far are sort of looking
at the universe on very large scales yes
but different kinds of particles make
different predictions for what dark
matter should look like on small scales
so this wimp we talked about yep it's
one version of a kind of particle that's
called cold dark matter and that
basically means it doesn't travel very
fast it's cold it's sort of heavy it
doesn't move as quick it doesn't move
very quickly and this other this warm
one kind of moves more quickly and the
consequence of that is that it most work
quickly so it actually erases the small
stuff and so you would actually expect
in those kind of models to have fewer
tiny galaxies than you would in the
models on the right and it makes lots of
interesting predictions for the numbers
and and how they do when you compare to
observation where does the observations
drive you toward left hand side right
hand side definitely so far to the left
hand side so there are versions of so
the most extreme version of warm dark
matter which hot dark matter is for
example Mary Angela mentioned nutrients
so that would be hot dark matter
we've art we have incredibly light
particles that's the key thing and they
move really fast and so all of those
little clumps would be erased and so
already so Joe was talking about the
dwarf galaxies actually in the last five
years or so we've discovered a whole
bunch more tiny galaxies that are
orbiting the Milky Way there's more than
50 now and we haven't seen gamma rays
from these galaxies but we do see that
even though they're super tiny the
tiniest ones have like 300 stars but
they see and maybe you look at how the
stars are moving it implies that they
have like a hundred million times the
mass of the Sun in dark matter and so
we've found a lot of those and that
actually kind of tells us that we don't
live in a universe which is mostly warm
dark matter it could be a tiny bit warm
that's like almost cold right there are
still a lot of sort of missing structure
if you look at this model it could
predict many more cliffs sub halos that
have not been observed yet I mean so
there's still something to be confirmed
these pictures here are just the dark
matter
not all of these are things that we
expect to light up so in our in the
context if the picture on the left is
correct then there would be a lot of
dark matter
we call them Dark Matter halos these
clumps of dark matter
we know that in in this model that above
like 10 to the 8th like a hundred
million times the mass of the Sun those
kinds of halos should form galaxies but
below that they're not in this model
that we wouldn't be able to see the
galaxies now there may be other ways to
see them that we're also thinking about
so let me ask you two questions along
those lines so there's a tendency in
trying to address the question of what
is the dark matter to think that there
is a thing a particular variety that
will explain all of the dark matter
could it be that the dark matter is a
sort of smorgasbord a few black holes a
couple of wimps you know some other
things mixed in it could it be a melange
in that way or is it going to be sort of
one thing I think it's totally possible
it's a Milosh I mean I think most of the
time we talk about dark matter is being
really simple because that's an easier
thing we want to say is the dark matter
a wimp is the dark matter in accion is
the dark matter black holes but you know
we don't know and if the dark stuff is
an outcome - you just have just one more
question before I forget it
you know could you imagine that the dark
stuff lives in a kind of dark sector
which has its own
I don't know standard model of particle
physics and as all these other thing but
it has no interactions with our world
besides gravity and therefore
extraordinarily difficult to directly
detect because it simply passes through
us without any impact beyond the
gravitational force which is incredibly
weak is that a possibility that you that
you pursue as well as that I think it's
definitely a possibility I think you
know we know that our owns we know the
standard model which we've actually
already mapped out is very complex yeah
so in that sense it's a little bit naive
to think that this whole the whole rest
of the universe is only one thing it's
just a simpler possibility to think
about so there could be like dark worlds
dark people dark everything in some dark
well most of the candidates we have
right now for dark matter would not
create dark worlds or dark people I
think that the Dark Sector models are
very interesting and with the null
results that have been coming out of
these experiments so far I've been
gaining a lot of attention over the last
few years and one of the things that's
really exciting I think about these
types of Dark Sector models is the types
of predictions that they make are very
different from the predictions that you
get for wimps so we have a whole slew of
experiments this massive experimental
program that's been really targeting
wimps from over the last few decades we
haven't seen it and now with all these
new ideas about these dark sector models
people are starting to think oh gosh
like we need to start branching out and
build different kinds of experiments so
that we can really capture the full
range of these possibilities so where do
things stand on on heading off into that
wild new territory that will differ from
the focus of attention for 30 years is
is that an active area now it's yeah
it's very active and but it's also not
like we're going into the big Wild West
we could do it very systematically so
you can say we have the standard model
we have a dark sector and then there's
certain rules for how that you can
communicate with each other it's a
finite set of rules so that that allows
us to list all of the possibilities and
then we can think about experiments that
would be targeting all of those
possibilities one very natural
consequence is that the Dark Matter
particle is lighter than you'd expect
for a wimp so just give us a sense of
scale when we talk about wimps the
typical size relative to the proton is
about 100 times as much right so when
you say light you mean so now we're
going down to like 10 to the minus 3 10
to minus 6 times the mass of the proton
right so considerably lighter so five
eight orders of magnitude yeah exactly
and and then that has significant
effects for how you look for it because
imagine that you build an experiment
where you want to look for a Dark Matter
particle coming in and knocking into
your target inside your experiment if
the Dark Matter particle is heavy it'll
come in and knock that target and you'll
be able to see it very easily if the
Dark Matter particle is light it'll come
in and it won't knock it and then we
never see the Dark Matter particle but
we can see the kick
the atom inside them what sort of atoms
are we imagining kicking in this yeah so
this well a lot of the experiments are
using xenon there's some experiments
using argon where are these experiments
we put these experiments deep
underground so usually like underneath
mountains or down the in mines because
the signals are so so faint you're
looking for these atoms just giving you
a slight little jiggle after these
collisions so you need to make sure that
you are sort of shielded from any other
kinds of backgrounds that can mock up
that type of signal and it's in this
scenario there have been signals at
least reported in the literature I don't
think any of them are really believed
right is that the general consensus yeah
that's right the current state of
affairs right now is that the there's
very strong limits from these
experiments that exclude whatever
signals were claimed by some other
experiments so the consensus right now
is that those other experiments haven't
been reproduced although there's
continuing efforts to try to and do the
the to those who have claimed positive
signals are they still supporting their
previous result are they also agreeing
that they're inconsistent with other
experiments and probably are not correct
no they're they're continuing to run and
continuing to stand by their original
results and it really will take
repeating that experiment by a separate
group using essentially exactly the same
type of setup to really be able to
confirm it one way or the other
now if the park is much lighter you're
about to tell us before interrupt you
sir so if it's much lighter than these
experiments would differ and some yeah
so if it's much lighter and it comes in
and it hits that nucleus the nucleus is
in and a jiggle very much and so it
becomes really hard to see it so but
building an experiment where you're
looking for those electron recoils is
different than an experiment is looking
for the nuclear recoils and so there's a
lot of brainstorming right now as to how
to do that and some initial efforts to
get that underway gotcha
so is it a fair summary to say that
there's a lot of indirect evidence for
the existence of dark matter the
searches to actually find it directly
are at best inconclusive but perhaps
some would even say it's beginning to
close the window on certain of the
favored candidates over the past so
three decades so it's a precarious
situation if it's something more exotic
like primordial black holes that that
would be an interesting approach but not
the one of the particle physics nature
and moreover as we also noted
supersymmetry forgetting about dark
matter we've looked for that at the
Large Hadron Collider we haven't seen
that either so that window is sort of
closing so that sort of as a natural
segue at least to thinking about
alternative approaches that might really
stand outside the the box of thinking
that people have been within for a long
time so Sarek why don't we turn now to
some of the things that you've been
thinking about which is I understand it
begins with trying to get a fuller grasp
on the underpinnings of gravity itself
and it's sort of a nice again day to be
talking about it general relativity
confirmed 100 years ago
you know today and that was at the time
the deepest understanding of the force
of gravity you're trying to go forward
from that so just give us a sense of
where you've been going in these ideas
yes so Einstein game but his theory are
more than 100 years ago and has been
confirmed and of course it has also been
very good in predicting things like
gravitational waves black holes and they
have been seen now so a lot of
predictions have come out and and have
been confirmed but this has to do with
gravity that's very strong it's a
particular where we see the dark matter
happening is something that where
gravity is very weak and this is where I
think modifications might happen and our
understand just give us a sense of that
so when you say strong you don't mean
that gravity is intrinsically strong you
mean there's more stuff right my stuff
or so acceleration is strong in this
where where a lot of matter is put
together if we look at larger scales
then then the accelerations are much
smaller these are more diffuse and more
diffuse but by thinking about black
holes in particular we have tried
learned more about where gravity kind of
comes
and this is sort of a development that
that started in the 70s with the work of
Stephen Hawking and I with my colleagues
have been thinking about these black
holes also by combining it with what we
know about quantum mechanics and then we
discovered that there is actually deep
relationship between gravity and well
entropy and thermodynamics and it's from
that those considerations that that we
start seeing that there's a deeper
understanding of what gravity comes so
can we pursue that just for a few
minutes just to give people a sense of
that so so can you tell us what like so
there's a little puzzle that was raised
I guess a long time ago by John Wheeler
yes so what was that so he was indeed
the first person to really ask questions
about black holes first of all that was
he he coined the name yeah black holes
112 Street and Broadway actually yeah I
know I'm not joking it was at the
Goddard Institute for Space Studies it
was during a talk but no black holes is
where the matter is so densely packed
that light cannot even escape and and
there's some some imaginary sphere
around it that if you go behind and
beyond that and you cannot escape
anymore we call that the horizon and so
John Wheeler asked the questions about
well the laws of thermodynamics also
whether they would apply in that
situation and so he had a thought
experiment where where is the a cup of
tea and so this is a cup of tea and in
the tea there are molecules going around
and there's a temperature and if you
look at the motion and all the the
random motion of those particles in
there they represent a certain amount of
entropy yep and you can think about
entropy as sort of telling you what are
all the possibilities that the tea can
be in and one thing you can do is apply
the laws of thermodynamics and an
entropy always has to increase and so we
asked us is also apply when we take a
black hole in neighborhood and throw the
cup of tea into the black hole because
what happens is that whatever it was in
the cup disappears from our view and the
entropy that is in there we don't see
anymore even if the cup breaks we would
not know it because it would go into the
black hole and everything disappears
then somehow this law of thermodynamics
that the entropy has increased has still
to apply so we ask the question where
does this entropy of the black hole
where where is it sitting and so Stephen
Hawking and also jacob bekenstein
basically answered that question and
they realized that when you throw
something into a black hole that the
horizon gets slightly bigger so the
black I'll eat some stuff and just gets
a little bigger yes and and they indeed
we then came with the proposal that the
amount of entropy that we souped
associated with it black hole is
actually given by the area of that
horizon and that was a beautiful idea
and they wrote down some beautiful
equations for it so this is the you need
a picture of the black hole and you can
see the horizon there and it is so if
you throw in one particle in the first
black hole the second black hole is
slightly bigger and it will have a bit
more information and this is this one
little bit that has been added so here
you see the other black hole which is
slightly bigger and we're gonna compare
indeed what is the amount of information
in there well squares on it and and that
actually represents one unit of
information and and this can be
described actually using indeed is these
laws of thermodynamics namely the mass
of the black hole represents a certain
amount of energy and the entropy is then
the area and indeed the area will
increase is the energy increases and
that's also the same equation that we
know from thermodynamics and now the
idea comes namely these thermodynamic
laws we can really explain by thinking
about the microscopic motion of
molecules so we understand precisely
what entropy is we know what temperature
means namely as a statistical measure of
the energy per particle and so we can
arrive those laws but now we want to
derive actually the same laws for
gravity actually they have the same form
and so the gravitational loss of black
holes and actually the einstein's
equations look like the equations that
well the thermodynamic equations in that
sort of a remarkable statement right I
mean thermodynamics was developed in the
in the 1800s and its ways to understand
things like you know steam engines the
things of that sort
and you're saying that there is a deep
relationship between those laws that
have nothing to do with gravity right
they just have to do with things that we
see in the world around us and you're
saying there's a deep connection between
those laws and the laws of gravity
that's correct and this is something we
have been discovering say over the last
three four decades and a particular last
10 years there's a big development
trying to indeed understand these
gravitational equations that Einstein
wrote down from this deeper underlying
description it's a you entropy some
principle you could have a conversation
with Albert Einstein and say al the
equations that you wrote down on
November 25th of 1915 I can give you a
deeper explanation for where they come
from yes and I think that is the same
way that he actually of course explained
in a deeper way what Newton's equations
were saying and so every theory in in
physics that we've known about
eventually will be surpassed and they
made it sort of well taken over by a
noodle theory doesn't mean that the old
theory is wrong
simply it's explained at a deeper deeper
level but there can be dense
circumstances where the new theory works
differently and this is where I think
indeed when we are dealing with horizons
and we can see these temperatures
appearing so one of the predictions of
Hawking was indeed that black holes
don't only have an entropy but also a
temperature and that they emit for
instance radiation and that's also a
remarkable statement because normally
when we talk about black holes we don't
imagine anything coming out of them yes
so this is indeed the discovery of
Hawking that black holes aren't really
black I mean black wouldn't mean that
nothing can come out but he discovered
that because of this quantum mechanical
properties of the horizon they carry a
temperature and that means that they
even really radiate and can possibly
even evaporate and so this is all about
black holes and of course you've been
talking about other things mean in the
universe about even also the dark energy
and what has to do with dark matter so
my idea
actually indeed is that we in order to
understand this dark matter phenomena
it's not sufficient to only focus on
that we also have to understand this
dark energy component that you talked
about I mean the fact that we don't
understand 95% of the energy in the
universe why would we focus only on one
component and I think that the dark
energy is first the thing that we also
have to understand more and better in a
microscopic way so when we spend a split
second on that since we mentioned it but
we didn't really say what it is so like
1998 this wonderful discovery that the
distant galaxies are rushing away ever
more quickly accelerated expansion of
the universe completely unexpected yes
as we sort of see here everybody thought
that over time the distant galaxies
would be rushing away ever more slowly
since gravity tends to pull things
together but it's going faster and
faster and the explanation that came out
in the late 90s was there's an energy
stuff using space it's dark it doesn't
give off light and it's giving rise to a
kind of a repulsive gravitational push
that's making everything rush away yes
so that's it's dark energy and and and
then so your view is that there's a
connection between dark energy and dark
matter yes I mean the fact that there's
dark energy in the universe has a very
important consequence and we indeed
things keep moving away from us and even
accelerating that also means that if we
look further things are moving away
faster and eventually there will be a
distance where things are moving away
with the speed of light and then you get
the beautiful conclusion and me that
acts like a horizon namely anything that
moves faster way with the speed of light
we cannot see anymore it's like indeed
with a black hole we cannot look what is
inside but now our own universe will
have some horizon that we cannot look
beyond and that is happening actually in
the universe that has only this dark
energy in it then the expansion is
actually rate is actually a constant
then what Hubble discovered this
expansion rate can be expressed in a
clinic yeah a constant that tells you
basically how large the universe is
because it will tell you where the
horizon is sitting and that horizon has
very
other properties as black hole horizons
and this is where I make the connection
between dark energy and the thing we
talk so let's let's hear it so the
connection you draw is is a following
namely that that the entropy that we
talked about that black holes have we
can also associate an entropy to the
horizon that our universe will have and
that horizon only appears because
there's actually dark energy in the
universe there's also a temperature
associated to death horizon so it
actually also satisfies all the laws of
thermodynamics but then you can ask well
where is this entropy and this
temperature associated to it's actually
associated to the dark energy that we've
added to our universe so I say that the
dark energy is the thing we really have
to understand because that will carry
also an entropy and a temperature which
is the one that we can calculate using
the same equations that that Hawking and
bekenstein found for black holes but
then applied to our universe dark energy
was essentially invented by la Mettrie
and then you know and discovered half a
century later it's a constant in our
science equations which Einstein himself
put in but the Metra realised that it
was due to these tiny quantum effects
and he even called it dark energy so a
constant of nature that could be the
dark energy and that accounts for
everything
it's a tiny constant we don't know where
it came from it dominates the universe
now gives us the acceleration but you
know there are other constants in nature
too though I don't think one is trying
to explain at the moment the unified
theory maybe someday we will what what's
wrong with that just saying dark energy
is this constant dark matter some some
other problem so this constant describes
more than 70% of the energy of our
universe and then we just put one
constant there well the 5% we're talking
about that is ordinary matter well
that's where all interesting stuff
happens that's our current theory and
that's precisely what I'm okay so for
black holes we would have said something
similar a black hole only has a mass
and well maybe it can rotate we would
not be able to explain its entropy by
thinking about a black hole in that way
in order to and explain that entropy
that's something we learned from string
theory we have to add many more degrees
of freedom and we have to indeed explain
these what's happening on on the horizon
of this black hole we have to do
something similar for our universe so
adding describing dark energy simply as
a constant is making an approximation
for instance that we can describe
everything that's here in the room by
just adding the temperature and that's
not describing really what's going on in
the room with all the motion of the
molecules that's in there so there's a
lot of things we're missing if we
describe dark energy with only one we
also heard a lot of very detailed
evidence of these beautiful simulations
that allow us to have a video on left
hand and right hand side which is
virtually indistinguishable at least to
the naked eye between simulation and
observation we see these beautiful
explanations of the rotations of
galaxies and so forth how far can you go
in in this novel approach to explaining
these kinds of detailed features of the
world without invoking say dark matter
so what is needed to describe the
observations is that there's an
additional gravity that keeps these
galaxies together I mean it's the
additional pool that we want to explain
so if there's an other explanation by
understanding gravity better that there
is an additional pool we can reproduce
many of these results so I see Dark
Matter almost as a sort placeholder in a
way that we can put it extra matter
there but we describe in effect that it
actually is due to the gravity itself so
when it comes to a simulations would
work in a very similar way if you would
have an understanding of gravity that
adds this additional force can you talk
about the the swirling yeah I mean the
beer Rubin you know observing you how
would you explain that okay so there
indeed I explained that I want to
understand the dark NSEL swirl also and
so dark energy
for me as an entropy in it but also when
the matter is there actually it has an
effect in interaction with this entropy
that's in the dark dark energy and we
can probably show this a min so indeed
this is what what you talked about
before namely this is the expectation
for this rotation curves where that
where on the vertical axis we have the
velocity into the right we have the
distance and then you see the velocity
going down what's actually being
observed is that it's indeed flattened
and there's an important hint in in how
where that happens turns out that it
happens at a moment when the
acceleration drops below a certain
critical value and if we express that
value numerically we find the connection
with the expansion rate of the universe
this Hubble constant to me that's an
important hint that there may be a
connection between what's happening here
and what is causing this expansion
namely the dark energy and so that
indeed I can explain why there would be
an additional force due to the dark
energy here's the the the galaxy that's
rotating and we won't understand why
there's an additional pool yeah but this
has to do with the presence of the dark
energy that's in there so if we take the
dark energy and add it to here you
actually will see that in this
neighborhood of the galaxy itself the
dark energy be has been expelled and it
tries to sort of reach or push back
again and it's sort of the interaction
between the dark energy and the matter
that's there well that will give the
additional force that is responsible for
keeping the galaxies together and it's
more than just pictures you're saying
that mathematical analysis so there is a
I will actually give a presentation here
tomorrow at the workshop where we'll
show these equations and indeed you can
work out numerically what is the
additional force one expects and you
find indeed it has the correct value to
predict actually even this flattening of
rotation curves this isn't in a
particular situation of course dark
matter is responsible for many other
things yes not just rotation curves of
galaxies it's used now to explain
structure formation and as we saw well
it's important for explaining what we
see in the cosmic microwave
background and for that indeed we need
to develop even the theory further so
that we can also explain those things
but they've not done that yet is that
well that's this idea so I have but it's
not like it has been worked out
completely but the thing that I realize
is that that what is needed and this is
sort of what makes these models work is
there is an extra component that gives
you an extract gravitational potential
what keeps things together but in all of
those calculations is never essential
that it's a particle the only thing that
really uses the additional gravitational
field so the particle nature of what now
is called dark matter has never is not
essential for those things so if I can
explain the same gravitational effect
without invoking dark matter
I can still reproduce many of those
calculations and the math may even be
very much the same so what do you guys
think you know you've been searching for
these particles for a long time haven't
found them and here's an approach that
may not need them convincing at all or
yeah you began the first demonstrations
of dark matter came with Ruben yes and
we saw a beautiful explanation with
using dark energy but also even before
that was Vicki yeah with clusters and it
turns out that if I think if you apply
your same theory to clusters you do all
the attempts so far need Dark Matter as
well otherwise one cannot fit this this
new type of theory of a Dark Matter
field to explain the motions of galaxies
new classes the ghost and fly part
otherwise that is that true do you agree
with what joe says so there are attempts
to sort of main all of the attempts
you're talking about a different
theories and then exit the one I wrote
down indeed where it would have a factor
that is too low I think in my case
actually can fit the outside of these
clusters the problem really appears more
in this in in the center where there is
usually a very strong concentration of
what then would be dark matter and here
I do believe that there may be our
explanations that are necessary but this
is certainly
a region where we're also supermassive
black holes have been formed and many
other things going on in the center part
of these clusters where I do think that
the the explanation of what being
observed there may have to do with even
understanding those phenomena in a more
fundamental way so so I agree a cluster
still provides a challenge certainly did
the central part of it the outer parts I
think I'm pretty confident that they can
be explained in the same way as I
explained the rotation curves for
galaxies so I mean I agree with Erik
that we haven't proven that it's a
particle and until we actually see
evidence you know of something that
comes from that particle then we won't
really be convinced but I think the
thing that is so compelling about the
idea of dark matter is that there are
these particles that are predicted as we
discuss for totally independent reasons
we didn't talk much about the acción
it's another particle that you know
could be the Dark Matter would behave
for structure formation very similarly
to the wimp and the thing that's so
compelling to me is that you take that
simple idea of you know take the
simplest version where it's one particle
and then you just use basic gravity as
we understand it and it makes a huge
range of predictions it predicts the
Cosmic Microwave Background it predicts
essentially the last 13 billion years of
our universe all the way from tiny
galaxies to the scale of the whole
universe and it does that in some sense
quite naturally and you do need a new
particle but but then you can make lots
of predictions right and you can test
them and we're testing them at very high
precision now yeah which is why the
community of physicists for so many
decades has had that as the paradigm
explanation but I guess the part that
feels deeply unsatisfying still is that
we've yet to actually get our hands on
it right it's very unsatisfying yeah but
you know there's lots of possibilities
right I mean I really hope we all right
you know figure out which one of them is
right but there's lots of possibilities
and we're just at the cusp
experimentally of being able to test
those possibilities so I actually think
that's what makes this field
so exciting would you say in the next
what are we looking next five years Nick
and if we had this conversation a decade
from now and assuming that funding
levels stay you know it's unclear you
know but but you know a decade for now
how would this conversation differ I
think we don't know I mean we could find
it you know in the next five years I
guess my question is is it conceivably
to come back ten years and we're still
mmm not sure or would it be we've ruled
out like dunt dunt dunt these huge
number of possibilities and it starts to
feel as though we're clutching at straws
in the particulate approach to dark
matter so my my view is that the pot the
range of possibilities is pretty big so
you know if we still haven't found a
wimp in ten years it probably doesn't
mean it's definitely not a women but it
means it's probably a wimp that's hard
to find
[Laughter]
that's a great song title and definitely
if we have this conversation in 10 years
we I guarantee you we will know a lot
more about what dark matter isn't Joe so
so just speculate ten years from now
where do you think will say here's
what's gonna happen in 10 years and I
know speculation here's what it is let
me even give you 50 years actually yeah
and so we're gonna build bigger
telescopes okay we're gonna feel bigger
accelerators and the reason is that
China is getting involved yeah they want
to build the world's biggest therefore
the West will do something similar to
and these will be accelerators ten times
more powerful than that it's CERN that
will take us to the limits of what the
Dark Matter particle could be will have
new types of gamma-ray telescopes and
then eventually we'll be building
telescopes on the moon which is a stable
platform no atmosphere bombarded for
billions of years by dark matter
particles and other things too
a great place to start doing research to
for dark matter so I think many many
experiments
very very expensive but science you know
at some point does get done and will get
done so I'm will discover something even
if it's not what we were looking for is
there just Mary owns that is there a
point in your career going forward where
you would say if we cross that threshold
and we haven't found the evidence for
dark matter of the direct sort that
we're talking about that you would say
you know it's time to change perspective
either do something else or or take on a
completely different approach well I
think we should always be keeping an
open mind and investigating completely
different approaches simultaneously but
I don't think that you know even if in
the course of my lifetime we never find
the dark matter particle that I mean
that seems like a totally viable
possibility to me I mean because when
when we just simply ask in the most
model independent fashion like let's set
aside Susie let's set aside blimps let's
set aside accion's and just ask what is
the range of masses that this Dark
Matter particle can be the most model
independent constraints that we can get
are just we need the Dark Matter mass to
be such that we can form galaxies and
the the mass range is orders of
magnitude it goes from 10 to the minus
22 electron volts all the way up to you
know black holes right and the wimps
which is what we've been spending all of
our time really most of our time really
focusing on there's a tiny tiny little
sliver in that space so in the next five
or ten years yeah I think you know given
the amount of effort we've put in that
sliver we'll probably know one way or
the other whether or not that hypothesis
was viable even that's the way science
works right you start off with the
hypothesis you see you pick the spot
where you think it's gonna be and then
you go for it and then you know you say
yes or no depending on what the evidence
gives you but as we move away from that
the possibilities are so huge and the
kinds of experimental signals that you
would look for in that range are so
diverse that you know it takes you know
very you know hundreds of years to just
sort it out almost we're lucky yep so
CEREC final question you know it's kind
of a funny situation to be in so you you
and I both string theorists yes which
famous
is a theory that has no experimental
evidence supporting it whatsoever
yeah and so the question that we're
generally asked is when do we give up on
these ideas and and yet beautifully
wonderfully you're pushing in a
direction that's trying to make contact
with observation but in a very
unexpected way because for so long the
community has fixated on dark matter as
a solution to the various problems that
we've spoken about here today
so how do you reconcile that I mean is
there a point where you think that we
will have gone so long without
confirming supersymmetry or finding
extra dimensions or any of the other
strange qualities that it's just too
speculative to push on this kind of a
direction and you could just say no and
we could finish the evening no no no I
don't think that the ideas we have
developed there are important and they
will teach you some more about what
gravitation is but I do think that as a
string theorist in the string theory
community we have to also ask questions
that can be connected to observations
and I do think that also cosmology is
one of those areas I mean at the moment
we are working with a cosmological
paradigm that uses dark matter and so on
and then it's based on general
relativity but I hope that we can
develop the string theory to the point
where we have a really this more
microscopic picture in terms of a theory
that combines it with quantum mechanics
and and then we can also understand for
insisted the universe with the dark
energy in it and I'm convinced that once
we have this theoretical framework we
can also address questions that have to
do with observations until that time I
think we should be looking for dark
matter and be having all these
experiments because sometimes you have
to look and test all the possibilities
before you get convinced there may be
another way of looking at this so I
think you should work on both sides why
we look at observations actually better
observations even of the phenomena that
are associated to is mean the expansion
history of the universe what's going on
in these galaxies and clusters getting
better
well precision data that will help I
mean I hope even that there will be time
that we can develop the theory our
string theory by being guided yeah by
observations and we go back to our whole
time when when they go hand in hand and
we all just get along no but but at the
eye I have certainly spent the last 10
years a lot of my time reading about
what people have been looking at in
cosmology and so on yeah because it can
give me also ideas of what direction to
look for and I do think our universe is
not the kind of universe that the string
theories are now studying I mean they're
mostly interested in a very idealized
model with no dark energy and which is
fully super symmetric and so on but that
doesn't seem to be describing our world
but if you wanted to understand what it
looks like in our world I think we also
have to take the data into account very
diplomatic so so thank you it's been a
fascinating conversation and hopefully
we will resolve this before 50 years
from now but but who knows so please
join me in thanking the group here thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]